bonjour retour du café politique sur
l'antenne de tv fil 78 les élections
départementales terminée nous retournons
ici au bistrot du théâtre à montigny le
bretonneux pour recevoir les élus locaux
pour parler de leur parcours est le
premier invité de ce mois d'avril c'est
henri pailleux bonjour bienvenue vous
est sereine avant l'ancien maire de
coignières commune d'un peu plus de 4000
habitants entre maurepas les essarts le
roi que vous avez dirigé depuis
1986 le dernier conseil municipal
c'était il ya quelques jours et vous
êtes parti parce que c'est un départ
motivé par un ras-le-bol général de la
politique on va y venir tout à l'heure
déjà tout d'abord merci d'avoir accepté
l'invitation parce qu'elle est un peu
plus de dix heures du matin et en
général la nuit vous travaillez et vous
êtes couché depuis pas très longtemps
vous avez travaillé encore cette nuit je
me suis couché à 7 heures du matin comme
d'habitude et comme tous les jours
d'ailleurs parce que je travaille tout
de nuit pour la mairie depuis 30 ans
maintenant maintenant que vous avez
décidé de quitter l'aja va pas changer
vous allez continuer tout un tas
d'activités de langues pourquoi
travailler la nuit justement et depuis
quand ça va mal depuis mes parents m'ont
mis chez les jésuites pour nous dresser
ses soeurs 1951 gt1 chahuteurs invétéré
et donc c'est là que j'ai appris à ne
pas me coucher du tout d'ailleurs et à
chahuter toute la nuit et ça ne m'a
jamais quitté vous n'êtes plus maire
depuis quelques petits nerfs depuis le
samedi 11 avril à 11 heures très
précises comment vous le vivez ce n'est
pas trop difficile prendre avec une
certaine nostalgie que l'on quitte quand
même une mairie
dans laquelle elle était depuis 29 ans
maintenant et sans compter que quand je
suis arrivé à coignières en 77 j'ai déjà
commencé à m'occuper des affaires de la
ville en créant le tennis-club de
coignières en devenant le syndic du
village et cetera donc ça fait 38 ans
que je suis au service du bien malgré
tout vous avez une certaine déception de
la vie politique en tout cas des hommes
politiques d'aujourd'hui vous êtes
convaincus de la totale déliquescence
des fondements et des valeurs mêmes de
la république absolument je suis
volistes je me suis d'ailleurs engagé en
politique en 1958 avec le retour du
herald de gaulle en 1959 était le plus
jeune encartés in vénère michel debré le
premier ministre avait pris sous sa
tutelle qui m'a présenté au général
c'était un grand bonheur pour moi à
l'époque je n'ai jamais revu après de
paea faim de loup un oui mais de prénom
mais ceci étant dis donc je suis resté
un gaulliste
toute ma vie et je continue donc à
essayer tant que faire se peut dans un
monde effectivement que je ne comprends
plus la france je ne comprends plus ce
qui s'y passe il ya plus d'éthique il ya
plus de morale l'intérêt général prend
le pas largement sur la terre est
particulière pardon sur l'intérêt
général et donc j'ai décidé que je ne
pouvais pas continuer à servir de
caution un système auquel je ne
comprends plus rien du tout vous avez le
sentiment de ne pas pouvoir le changer
de ce système en tout cas à votre
échelle vous savez si j'avais des
chances de pouvoir changer le système
est bien
bien effectivement je m'y attendrai mais
à mon âge maintenant c'est terminé et
puis je vois bien que c'est une société
qui courent delannoy et qui m'est cher
une certaine résignation
non je ne suis pas aigri 1 je suis
simplement malheureux
c'est le mot quels sont les événements
politiques qui vous ont le plus déçu que
ce soit à l'échelle de votre commune que
ce soit être à l'échelle nationale pour
aujourd'hui arrivée dans cette série-là
déliquescent je dirais qui se fait jour
depuis la disparition de georges
pompidou le gaullisme restons tous quand
j'irai dans l'esprit des français alors
évidemment les hommes politiques et bien
ma foi font toujours référence au
général de gaulle même les socialistes
qu'ils l'ont combattu en 1932 60 69
donc c'est une tv questions générales
alors bien évidemment j'ai été marqué
par un serveur de choses je me souviens
que je n'étais pas d'accord avec
l'abandon de la chair des françaises
avec michel debré au départ mais on a
bien dû s'y faire et on a bien et j'ai
bien reconnu par la suite que le général
avait eu raison on ne pouvait pas rester
dans les airs et ce n'était pas possible
et puis ensuite j'ai soutenu jacques
chirac je dirais j'étais toutes ces
campagnes présidentielles
j'étais partout j'étais à toulouse à
marseille partout je le suis bien que
comme son nom et là dessus il m'a fait
un quinquennat était une catastrophe
absolument invraisemblable
d'abord on a second quinquennat déjà
première bêtise et ensuite alors quand
il m'a boycotter au service je dirais
moi qui suis un bonapartiste j'irai
aussi convaincu je suis gaulliste là
j'ai pas compris du tout bon je lui ai
écrit mais il m'a pas répondu vous avez
75 ans 30 ans à la tête d'une même
commune 14 ans au conseil général des
yvelines dont 4 à la vice-présidence
également et pourtant
en vraiment vous destiné à la politique
vous est tout sauf carriériste non rien
du tout non j'ai été on va dire un mot
les militants extrêmement actif de 1958
à 1983 au fil de lumière c'était mon
premier mandat donc je ne faisais que
khatami à mi-temps partouche n'a jamais
vraiment extrêmement actifs sains et
puis c'est en 83 donc mon prédécesseur
et bien m'a appelé dans son équipe
municipale ou plutôt c'est moi
d'ailleurs qui sont venus le convaincre
de partir parce qu'il ne voulait pas
repartir aux municipales 83 on a gagné
il m'a nommé adjoint et en 86 il a
décidé de partir et il a dit qu'il va
tomber de de le remplacer je n'y étais
pas du tout préparés parce que j'ai avec
des professionnels dans le nucléaire je
dirais extrêmement prenante et rien qui
vous destiné à la politique si ce n'est
le caractère peut être celui que vous
avez hérité de votre grand mère bretonne
alors vous avez récemment est tout à
fait vous avez récemment publié un livre
la force de la conviction aux éditions
de l'archipel et vous en parlait
beaucoup de votre grand mère elle vous a
enseigné et je vous cite l intégrité la
publicité la volonté de tracer votre
route en dehors des clous un sommet
important que c'était une grand mère je
dirais très particulier il valait mieux
ne pas les croiser parce que il risque
de vous arriver
les processus et viraient immédiatement
non elle était vraiment extrêmement
volontariste et puis bon c'était était
son seul petit fils au départ entre les
clubs se dire et j'ai eu des soeurs et
elle m'avait pris elle alors ce sont
elles me protégeait de mon père parce
que mon père lui était un coup de bâton
que ça se passait en permanence donc
effectivement ma grand mère m'a beaucoup
aidé et je lirai dans ma vie et après
tout peut-être que je tiens un peu de
son créateur s'est rangé votre caractère
votre détermination vos convictions
absolument saint jouin rôle important
oui mais il ya les jésuites derrière
aussi qui fissurent millions parce que
j'étais un chèque le chenapan eleven
henri paillet très mauvaise élève
indiscipliné aussi ce sont des défauts
qu'on n'attend pas trop pour un homme
politique pourtant bah oui mais ces
lieux c'était difficile à l'école
était sévère d'ailleurs pour vous
protéger vous l'avez du quai à coups de
bâton tout plaquer et c'est
à la maison où ce soit d'ailleurs celle
éligibles c'est lui qui vous envoie
jésuites à ce que parce que
on était à soissons en cinq ans j'ai
fait des cinq écoles de 60 à chaque fin
d'année c'était virer jackson et
lorsqu'on est arrivé à la 5ème n'avait
pu et donc il me coller franchement j'ai
lier changement parce que c'est un
chanoine qui s'est occupé de votre
formation et éducation jean coup
quel rôle il a joué ce personnage dans
votre éducation qu elle
c'est fabuleux parce que donc ils
étaient ils étaient chanoine il avait
été président de la délégation spéciale
à compiègne mise en place donc il a
assuré également la mairie de deux
compagnies à l'époque ce qui veut dire
parce qu'ils avaient des mariages il est
marié d'abord à la mairie et ensuite il
est marié à l'église
c'était un monsieur je dirais d'une
grande rigueur d'une grande exigence qui
avaient des connaissances à bulles que
les enseigner le latin le grec la
philosophie parler l'allemand il parlait
l'anglais ils parlaient espagnol et
italien
et
là dessus je sais pas pourquoi il a
décidé de prendre en main il me dresser
ça n'a pas été facile parce que c'était
un combat de tous les jours avec des
ailes a réussi et bien ma foi
quand j'étais mon entrée c'était en
sixième allez
j'ai commencé il a commencé finalement
avoir quelques résultats avec moi au
niveau de la troisième on va faire une
ellipse un forcément de votre parcours
parce qu'ensuite il irait parcours
professionnel est là aussi vous l'avez
évoqué rapidement tout à l'heure c'est
vers le nucléaire que vous êtes tourné
oui elle pas du tout dans la politique
nourrie au départ j'étais
la faculté des sciences d'orsay en
physique des solides c'est là que j'ai
connu pierre gilles de gennes qui était
mon professeur de thèse avec hubert
curien d'ailleurs donc des gens très
célèbre
j'ai eu cette chance et j'ai préparé un
doctorat et donc j'étais à la fois
chercheur et enseignant de physique à
l'université
et puis en 75 tiens comme aujourd'hui la
politique vous là le vo lu tion de la
france je ne comprenais plus
l'université je me suis dit que je
n'avais pas une vocation de chercheurs
et qu' il fallait que je trouve quelque
chose ailleurs et c'est comme ça que
j'ai fait mon entrée donc la technique
atom pour travailler dans l'énergie
nucléaire pendant deux ans sur le
développement et kurt humanitaire et
puis après sur les réacteurs
surgénérateurs phénix et superphénix
vous installer à coignières vous
apprenez à la vitesse habitait créteil à
l'époque que je déménage sur coignières
et puis donc je travaillais au départ au
cea pas j'ai travaillé à nos bateaux
mais c'était aussi ce robinson après
j'ai travaillé à la cogema qui était à
vélizy d'envoyer tout ça dans le même
secteur en gros et j'ai pris ma retraite
donc en 2005
parce que vous avez continué à
travailler
à côté de votre activité de mer mais
malgré tout il a fallu faire un choix un
moment entre s'impliquer plus à la
mairie dans la vie municipale ou suivre
d'un pôle déménagement ce n'était pas
facile à gérer vous le dis parce que
quand j'avais le le conseil général je
voulais pas y aller au clash qui va
obliger à les voulais pas y aller j'y
étais pour lui faire plaisir parce que
j'étais sûr de perdre monde de shanghai
et là je me retrouve dans une situation
où j'avais de la mairie le conseil
général mon activité professionnelle mon
activité politique et puis toutes sortes
de passion par ailleurs bonaparte
napoléon de vol etc et comme je suis
très actif et donc tout au début dans
les années 80 je ne dormais que deux
afin jours et qu'elle voit elle ne
dormait pas du tout
on va marquer une pause dans un instant
on va aller s'installer en salle pour
évoquer cette fois ci plus en détail le
travail que vous avez menées sur la
ville de coignières pendant près de
trente ans une dernière question depuis
le début de cette émission vous dites
que vous êtes gaulliste bonapartiste
oleg aujourd'hui en 2015 ça signifie
quoi être gaulliste et bonapartiste
ça signifie quoi bein je dirais que j'ai
je suis un grand admirateur du général
de gaulle
tout simplement parce que c'est un homme
qui a redonné à la france sa dimension
quant à bonaparte mais pas vous en
parler vous savez très bien que même
encore aujourd'hui on ne vit qu'avec
tout ce qu'il a mis en place c'était un
homme fabuleux tout le monde connaît
l'art militaire de napoléon qui
s'enseigne à ce point ces secours sur 43
mais les français mam ignore ses
qualités de législateurs et
d'administrateurs et de terminer pour
moi c'est le directeur de roanne n'est
pas le superintendant pour moi napoléon
c'est la quintessence de l'intelligence
humaine eh bien je pense comme lui voilà
une courte pause et cafés politiques ça
poursuit
à
seconde partie du café politique
toujours avec henri bayeux nous allons
reparler à plus longuement à présent des
années que vous avez passées à la tête
de la commune de coignières on va parler
donc de cette ville on me disait tout à
l'heure vous en étiez maire depuis
1986 quelle image on va garder de vous
les habitants voici quelques réponses
que nous avons collectés dans les rues
de votre commune tient bon mais on a
beaucoup d'estimé pour lui une ville
propre bien organisés à mr cohérent avec
ce qui nous a annoncé à chaque fois
depuis le temps donc et pas de problème
dans ce qui fait beaucoup de choses pour
son propre intérêt ou
l'intérêt de des gens qui l'entourent et
non pas pour les administrés il a tout
fait pour les riches alors faire de
nouvelles voies nous regarder nos routes
regardez l'état de nos routes vous
verrez les routes sont tout casser il
fait rien à part mettre des caméras
autour de la cité pour nous surveiller
comme il disait tout ce qui fait c'est
une personne bas tout à fait convenable
qui a fait beaucoup de choses ici à la
ville il est critique évidemment s'il ya
que celui différé est pas compliqué on
est d'accord je pense qu'il a fait pas
mal de choses pour la commune bon
maintenant il est temps peut-être qui
passe sa main une réaction parce que
vous avez entendu des réactions chez
les choses pareilles
bon d'accord quand vous entendez il ya
certaines choses m'ont est temps de
passer la main par exemple
que la région 75 ans et sur les êtres
une réaction sur ce que disaient les
plus jeunes il nous a pas aidé et
soutien les les plus riches et gèle et
séduit les plus riches ce sont au
contraire les plus pauvres à coignières
que j'ai soutenu et c'est parce que je
me suis rendu compte que coignet arrêter
la ville au niveau de ses administrés
parmi ceux qui étaient des recrues des
salaires les plus bas
en
88/89 je ne suis pas exactement dans le
parisien il y avait un article donc sur
262 communes des départements des
yvelines coignières haut niveau sa
richesse et ses habitants étaient en
deux cent cinquante neuvième place juste
derrière trappe voilà et c'est là que
j'ai compris que j'avais un devoir
s'était développée est connu dans la
ville de coignières de façon à permettre
justement d'avoir la fiscalité la plus
basse et les services aux prix les plus
bas
agréable les impôts sont deux fois
inférieur à toutes les communes qui nous
entoure et en 86 la ville est terminée
là dessus donc j'ai fait du lobbying
pour étirer le commerce parce que j'ai
avec les terrains disponibles
j'ai fait tout ce qu'il était nécessaire
de faire donc pour enrichir la commune
en 95 le pari était venu j'avais dit
viser la fiscalité par deux à l'époque
donc pour y parvenir en 95 étaient
inquiets depuis 95 et même plus besoin
d'aller chercher les entreprises c'est
elle qui viennent me voir naturellement
maintenant pour s'installer à cueillir
manière comme une autre russe
alors donc effectivement en 1986
coignières était la 212e vie de la plus
riche par habitant est aujourd'hui elle
est au deuxième rang derrière vélizy
villacoublay et le fait d'avoir fait
venir sur coignières tous ces
commerçants le long de la nationale 10
notamment il ya aucun regret aujourd'hui
de voir cette ville et est très
développée que c'est presque une ville
de passage absolument pas c'est une
ville très atypique il faut savoir les
deux tiers des villes de coignières
seront encore en zone rurale forêts et
champs
avec lui avec une grande ferme et que à
peu près le reste partagée pour moitié
en zone d'habitat et pour moitié en
scène économique un peu plus du côté des
hôtes économique et je ne le regrette
pas parce que c'est grâce à ça que j'ai
réussi à doter coignières d'équipements
que jalouseraient des villes de 20
millions d'habitants est actuellement à
coignières tout est neuf tout est fait
il n'y a qu'une chose changera pas de
piscine parce que gérer une piscine en
ville universitaire ça m'a ruiné et donc
il ya une piscine à maurepas il ya une
piscine nos essais
tant que je serai là c'est terminé et
bien de tous malienne il aurait jamais
piscine à coignières et je m'y opposerai
si par hasard on sait que ce rôle est
enfermé à mon avis à mettre la main une
proximité importante avec les habitants
de coignières ça c'est un élément qui a
dicté tout le long de votre de vos
années passées à la tête de la commune
et je vais leur préciser parce que c'est
pas le cas pour tous les maires mais
vous habitez coignières oui je l'avoué
dans cette ville pour moi il n'est pas
question je voudrais pas été quelque
chose que je puisse habiter ailleurs que
ça aurait été totale oui je sais ça
aurait été totalement épouse
j'ai toujours été extrêmement proche des
gens j'ai développé à coignières un
nombre de gérer des animations de fêtes
de celle à fait accueillir tous les
jours quel immense bond
d'ailleurs le quand j'organise des
manifestations des banquets ou autres
lots est interdite sur ma table
sauf pour leur sort pour le banquet des
rois traiter parce que j'ai là le doyen
et la doyenne contre 90 cents ans et je
me dis que peut pas les forcer quand
même je dirais à revoir le vin que
jacques sordes abondamment pendant le
repas donc je
me voyais dans cette plaquette là que
j'ai rédigée pour mon départ
c'était une plaquette de façon de passe
il ya tout ce que j'ai fait à quoi dire
là donc la remettrait tout à l'intérieur
c'est intéressant et là-dessus la
dernière partie porte justement sur la
ville conviviale que j'ai voulu
construire tout le monde à sa face à
coignières les anciens les jeunes de
tout le monde et l'opposition aussi
quels rapports vous avez votre position
dans cette commune baba fois
votre liste est apolitique ont dirigé la
ville
quand je disais que connaît les corps et
mansle atypique faut savoir que kony
revote à gauche à 60%
tout le monde sait à coignières que
j'étais rpr ump aujourd'hui il n'empêche
qu'ils vont toujours élu avec des scores
entre 60 et 70% voire 100% warsh
enclenchant 795 panélistes et glaou j'ai
été le plus surpris c'est qu'aux
cantonales en 94 et en 2001 le connais
rien mois accordé 72 % de voix
donc c'est une ville assez atypique l or
mais rapport à l'opposition sont
excellents ils sont ils ont toujours été
de tout le maillage des associés fois le
mieux que je pouvais faire à la gestion
du sipal mais bien évidemment dans
l'opposition parce que c'est
d'opposition faut bien qu'elle s'oppose
par exemple didier fischer a reproché
dernier budget parce que j'ai tenus
assuré vendredi dernier le dernier
budget primitif qui est le budget
primitif 2015 ou jours dans des impôts
10% j'ai essayé de bien expliquer
pourquoi et bien tout simplement parce
que l'état de lakes 2 dotation
extrêmement importante que j'étais
coincé je pouvais pas faire autrement
vous aviez baisser les enfants juste
avant en 2013 j'avais baissé tout
simplement parce qu'en 2003 je disposer
de réserves très importantes liées aux
économies avaient fait sur les gros
investissements qui ont été faits lors
du dernier mandat donc j'avais plein
d'argent je me suis dit que j'allais
leur distribuer aux connais rien sous
forme non seulement d'une baisse des
impôts de 10 % mais également gbc tous
les services cantine centre aéré
garderie de 10% également à l'époque
aujourd'hui je suis pris en ciseaux je
dirais par les décisions
gouvernementales et celles de l'état est
derrière toutes les communes de france
et de navarre on te voir augmenter la
fiscalité et comme je pense est un
excellent gestionnaire ce que ne pense
pas à des guérisseurs et lui me dit que
j'ai pas le droit de faire ce que je
fais et bien dès le budget 2015 je
commence déjà engrangé de l'argent pour
préparer pour mon successeur 2016 2017
et après parce que je sais qu'en 2016
sera pire qu'en 2015 du côté de l'état
et qu'en 2017 ce sera également pire et
l'état de la déjà annoncées donc je
prends de la vence j'engrange de
l'argent ceux qui nous reprochent
d'après me c'est pas loin d'avoir fait
de l'argent alors je lui ai posé là
quelque chose il faut dire quand vous
avez acheté votre pavillon vous n'avez
pas fait des économies ou pendant une
dizaine d'années sur un bûcher ménage
entre les comme moi c'est ce que j'ai
fait eh ben je fais pareil pour la
commune parce que j'ai toujours géré la
commune en bon père de famille sans
prendre absolument aucun risque pour
personne didier fischer on va l'écouter
ajustements sa réaction lors de votre
dernier conseil municipal celui qui a vu
jean-pierre sevestre prendre la tête de
la commune à des différences évidemment
politique sur un certain nombre de
sujets je les exprime assez
régulièrement en conseil municipal et
quelquefois même dans la presse henri
pailleux est ce qu'il est
ça a été un maire actifs et je pense
qu'un certain nombre de paniers rien
s'ils ont réélu depuis 30 ans considère
qu'il a été un bon maire est bien mais
rossi qui a un caractère et une
personnalité très forte
caractère personnalités à très forte
avec tout de même des habitants il l'a
rappelé un qui nous ont suivis pendant
trente ans de quoi vous êtes le plus
fier sur votre commune et bien ce dont
je suis le plus fier c'est d'avoir
développé économiquement première comme
je lé fais d'en avoir fait donc la ville
la plus riche département par habitant
je lirai en deuxième position derrière
vélizy ce qui m'a permis de dégager des
moyens pour avoir une fiscalité parmi
les plus faibles donc c'est ça et puis
ensuite j'ai eu comme de grandes
réalisations à mon actif l'espace
alphonse daudet d'une part la
réhabilitation de la mairie d'autre part
et puis l'achat également des de la
résidence des personnes âgées qui aurait
pu être acheté par le privé les loyers
auraient doublé ou triplé et puis
également les salons tonnes les super et
donc que serge dassault m'a offert dans
d'excellentes conditions financières
donc et puis alors surtout évidemment
toujours en arrière-plan du
développement économique de la ville
j'ai quand même créé je dirais sur le
but de produire depuis 86 près de 6000
emplois vous allez surveiller ce qu'elle
va faire votre prédécesseur votre
successeur pardon
municipal non je reste au conseil
municipal message est assez logique et
c'est assez normal mais je ne reste pas
là je dirais pour surveiller
jean pierre sauvestre donc
bien évidemment je vous révèle sur ce
qu'il va faire je ne pense pas qu'il
sorte je dirais du cadre tel que j'ai
tracée depuis 30 ans enfin après tout on
ne sait jamais et donc je serai là je
dirais pour garantir ou essayer de
garantir la continuité mais je n'ai pas
d'inquiétude j'en percevais c'est un
garçon sérieux c'est un bosseur qui
était présent sur le terrain également
et je pense qu'il a toutes les qualités
pour gérer la vie un dernier mot on va
parler on en a assez peu parlé à tout de
même de votre passage au conseil général
vous en avez été vice-président 2008 ça
s'arrête en raison d'une division des
voix à droite dissidente à la vôtre une
liste menée par le premier adjoint des
longs cours appuyé par le maire
d'elancourt maire d'elancourt qui
d'ailleurs vient dans cette fois ci
d'être élu conseiller départemental en
mars dernier est un peu l'ironie de
l'histoire on n'est jamais trahi que
dans son propre camp oui absolument
c'est une histoire extrêmement
douloureuse j'étais vice président
sortant du conseil général j'avais fait
basculer en 94 alors que je ne le
cherchez pas je pensais que j'allais
être battu et je le souhaitais pas ce
même d'être battu et quand le peu de
temps que j'avais
pour la première fois j'ai fait basculer
le canton de maurepas donc à droite et
là dessus je suis réélu en 2001 déjà
avec des bâtons dans les roues de jean
michel fourgous et en 2008 alors je suis
vice président sortant eh bien ils
décident de présenté son premier
engagement en dissidence
j'ai fait appel bien évidemment alors au
niveau départemental et j'avais été
investi par 481 voix sans 495 d'ailleurs
michel jean michel fourgous qui
donnerait son investiture serait
l'encours dans la obtenu de 350 ou 355
et bien il a donc lancé son premier
adjoint en dissidence contre moi j'ai
fait appel au national jean michel
fourgous a été condamné
et on lui a demandé de retirer sa
dissidence il ne l'a pas fait et le
deuxième tour il y avait jean michel
favier et moi-même bon travail c'est
lire et les oies se divise et puis mon
père étant que ismaël ivan donc qui
représenterait le parti socialiste a
remporté le canto dans cet ouvrage la
force de la conviction la fin de ce
paragraphe consacré au conseil général
vous dîtes surtout qu'on ne prononce pas
le nom de jean michel fourgous en ma
présence absolument mais jean michel
foucher est interdit de venir à même de
battre des pieds sur la commune de poil
hier et je refuse au nord aucune date
n'est
pas une question de rancune tenace non
il m'a mené une campagne d'une horreur
tellement invraisemblable que en cours
de campagne je me souviens de georges
mougeot perdre nos repères de longs
repas de l'époque de gauche et pierre
c'est lincourt communiste rmr de la
verrière je me souviens que l'un l'autre
m'ont téléphoné à à peu près à une
petite heure d'intervalle chez moi pour
me dire tu as été pour sa boîte aux
lettres ça fait bien et a dit non ben
écoute tu vas le chercher mais tu
t'assois avant de lire c'était une
horreur jamais je n'ai alors ils m'ont
dit on a 40 ans de politique derrière
nous c'est une nouveau et c'est l'un
qu'hôpital on n'a jamais vu un tel sort
un prononcer sur une personne c'est un
des épisodes les plus douloureux de
votre vie politique je dirais que
oui c'était assez désastreux on a perdu
le canton et puis là dessus je n'ai pas
accepté la vérité en procès tous à vous
et puis il a été et il a perdu jean
michel fourgous merci henri pailleuse
donc ancien maire de coignières mais
vous restez conseiller municipal je
rappelle cet ouvrage que vous avez écrit
avec sandrine roudeix la force de la
conviction c est aux éditions de l
archipel merci à vous le prochain est
cassée politique ce sera le premier mais
d'ici là je vous retrouve tous les soirs
du lundi au vendredi 18 heures pour le
journal